[Aplausos]
[Música]
en las dos últimas conferencias que me
hacen cambiar la introducción la
educación tampoco es neutra la ocasión
tiene que tener una postura neutra
pero quería comenzar diciéndolo
diciéndoles que el ser humano es el
único que le puede dar energía valor a
las palabras es el único y cuando estas
palabras penetran internamente en
nosotros cuando se hacen vida con
nosotros en nuestro espíritu ésta se
convierte en la fuerza positiva de
nuestra gusta actuar estas palabras que
quiero compartir con ustedes se pueden
convertir en palabras que forjan sueños
en palabras que transforman realidades
en palabras que pueden ser eternas si
las cantamos o las contamos como dice el
poeta
las coplas mientras no las cante el
pueblo
coplas no son y cuando las canta el
pueblo ya nadie sabe su autor procuran
tu ustedes yo que tus coplas tus
acciones tus palabras vayan al pueblo a
parar
aunque ya no sean tuyas para hacer los
demás y recuerda que cuando el corazón
se funde con el alma popular lo que se
pierde de nombre se gana en el pérdida
de esto lo que queremos decir estas
coplas de manuel machado en la que me ha
acompañado desde mi juventud y ha
retomado mi alma
para poder convertirse a los pocos en
esta caminada de educador a convertirse
en el horizonte para seguir caminando
tenemos que cantarlas el horizonte
que me enseñaron en mi escuela de ser
más para servir mejor el horizonte que
tiene o que tenemos que cantar juntos la
solidaridad el amor la fraternidad esto
lo que yo quiero contarles con tres
palabras fundamentales que tengo en este
caminar de educación la educación no es
libre de procesos internos la educación
está cargada de procesos que tienen que
ver con el pueblo
cuál es la primera palabra
y ustedes van a decir bueno va a ser dos
palabras pero no las puedo separar
porque la una se complementa con la otra
no solamente se como 90 se dan vida y
esto lo importante esto lo que quiero
resignificar en esta tarde esto lo que
quiero cantar de nuevo en esta tarde es
educación popular
obviamente didácticamente podemos decir
que educación viene de una raíz latina
que es educar que significa sacar de
dentro ya los griegos nos decían eso
sacar de dentro y que lo que implica
para esta educación es que las personas
que están que nos que nos apoyamos en
este proceso educativo
hacemos partícipe al sujeto de su propia
educación serán los niños ser las
personas adultas las que están
educándose las que tienen el derecho de
ser partícipe de su propia historia
ellos son los sujetos de esta historia
pero esta palabra educativas y purita no
puede seguir formándose con tantos
currículos y tantas cosas tiene que
tener el complemento de lo popular y eso
es lo que quiero rescatar qué significa
lo popular
lo popular le va a dar escuchen muy bien
la razón de actuar de la educación
que también viene de una raíz latina
popularice pero no es lo que desquició
soy popular o usted es popular esto no
tiene nada que ver o que si las cosas
solamente son más baratas para lo
popular lo que no vale no es que lo
popular son los pobres que le piden un
regalito en la esquina usted no no no
eso no es lo popular lo popular dentro
del proyecto educativo dentro de
educación popular nos va a incitar a
mirar la dya la realidad a escucharla es
lo que hemos dicho aquí a escucharla a
mirarla a tener los sentidos abiertos
porque es el contexto en donde yo estoy
que el que tiene que ver para que yo
pueda ser el maestro más que el profesor
el maestro porque profesor es una
profesión maestro es una misión
yo tengo una misión que tengo que era
estar haciendo para construir entonces
lo popular
la educación popular le va a decir oye
escucha la realidad
y la realidad te va a preguntar he aquí
el problema te va a preguntar muchas
realidades humanas y de cosas de
paisajes aquí viene el papá esta
universidad y nos hizo una pregunta que
no creo que hayamos contestado a la
universidad
nos preguntó cómo no sé se acuerda
algunos que fue que preguntó el papá
dónde están tus hermanos dónde están los
que no pueden venir aquí es tu
diversidad dónde están tus hermanos
y la realidad nos pregunta dónde están
los que aún a fraga 2
donde están los miles de niños que no
puede ir a la escuela
solo en el ecuador en la edad de 0 a 4
años son un millón de niños que no
tienen educación en el país niños
dicho por la unicef ahora en la mesa que
estuve
hay más de 150.000 niños que tampoco
pueden ir a la escuela básica y más de
100.000 al bachillerato
qué hacemos que nos preguntamos ante esa
realidad como la enfrentamos 12 la
educación popular nos va a decir no hay
educación sin transformación social
no hay educación sin transformación
social y la transformación es hacer
realidad que no haya injusticias
educativas en este mundo
eso no va a decir la educación popular
pero cómo se aprende esto
desde donde los sentimos
y claro esto no se aprende en cuatro
paredes
yo lo aprendí en mi colegio en los
campamentos algo aprendí yo ya vamos a
hablar después de los campamentos y lo
hice mío cuando llegué a fe alegría fe
alegría de ecuador
qué alegría tiene aquí en el ecuador 74
centros educativos de todos niveles de
inclusión de todo lo que hemos hablado
acá somos 32 mil niños entre jóvenes y
adultos estudiando
somos más de 1500 entre profesores y
administrativos en fe y alegría tenemos
54 años y en el mundo estamos en 23
países más de un millón y medio cantando
las palabras eternas de educación
popular más de un millón y medio con
miles de personas como ustedes
colaborando desde un proyecto no de un
real no de una mendicidad sino de que
todos somos responsables por la
educación de un pueblo todos somos
responsables ya no queremos más que
salgan los profesionales nosotros
exitosos a mundos que todavía están para
cuando se la miseria esa idea no me cabe
en la cabeza como es posible que yo sea
exitoso mientras más
de la tercera parte de nuestro pueblo
está la miseria
no lo entiendo como seguimos pensando
así pero claro
este proyecto de educación popular está
resignificación de esta palabra yo no la
quiero mirar desde las controversias y
no estoy aquí haciendo política entre
izquierda y derecha ni la quiero mirar
desde la lucha de clase en la eterna
lucha de clase ricos y pobres no no no
esta ubicación de la educación popular
la reformulación de esta palabra tiene
que ser desde el deseo de que todos
tenemos que saber que somos responsables
por lo humano y por el mundo en que
vivimos todos
si nosotros no nos amamos no nos
cuidamos no tenemos historias como decía
aquí maría fernanda restrepo si no
hacemos que los todos tengamos esta
historia
no podemos construir un país si yo
solamente pienso en mi triunfo no
podemos contra un país la educación
popular implica el que todos nos
involucremos en una esperanza de vida
para todo un pueblo eso lo que quiero
cantar y esa era la primera palabra que
quería exponer con ustedes pero
a medida que fui caminando en este
proyecto educación popular
y a medida de leer historias de hombres
y de mujeres
que creo que es nace uno cada 100 años
ahí tienen ustedes matter luther king la
madre teresa bueno mucha gente que van
haciendo y que abandonando su vida a
este canto popular yo me encuentro
coke
este señor de la áfrica nelson mandela
leyendo su historia su biografía me
encuentro con una palabra mi segunda
palabra
con esto con una palabra que está en las
redes sociales también encontré antes
que las redes pero se llama ubuntu
ubuntu
[Música]
el lenguaje su luz africano va a
significar yo soy porque los demás son
yo soy persona porque los otros me han
enseñado a ser persona porque los otros
son personas
yo soy porque los demás son traduciendo
la nosotros los humanos somos porque
otros humanos son desde esa perspectiva
a mí me importa el tú me importa un yo
porque todos juntos nos importa un
nosotros que construye sociedad que
construye comunidad y de ahí viene el
amigo pablo freire de esta educación y
nosotros otro más de la pedagogía
crítica que nos dice nadie aprende solo
nadie aprende sólo aprendemos en
comunidad
y la educación elba decir no es neutra
por eso una educación de todo un pueblo
universitaria primaria secundaria como
la llamemos tiene que tener unos
objetivos muy claros y en fin alegría
decimos que la educación popular tiene
objetivos éticos no toda ética no todo
vale en la vida es la ética cuál es el
proyecto ético en este proceso
pedagógico o de aprendizaje tiene que
tener un proyecto político
de transformación donde todos podamos
tener las mismas posibilidades y tiene
que tener un proyecto obviamente
pedagógico de que pedagogía estamos
hablando que estamos enseñando y
obviamente la forma de aprender y de
conocer dentro del proyecto
epistemológico esto lo que tienen que
tener esta palabra todos somos
responsables y aquí como lo aprendemos y
aquí yo cuento pequeña historia nada más
desde muy pequeño yo soy de portoviejo
me eduqué el colegio cristo rey de los
jesuitas y me encontré con un amigo
jesuita josé ignacio mendoza que
construyó campamento al estilo al estilo
boy scaut campamentos iríamos cada fin
de semana 300 200 objetos que las
jóvenes hombres y mujeres ya en los años
ya a finales los años 70 imaginen
cuántos años tengo yo soy joven más pero
ya dicom vivíamos en comunidades donde
juntos íbamos con nuestras mochilas a
hablar de nosotros el silencio lo
importante para mirarnos para ver qué
piensa el otro que te dice cómo te
evalúan si no eras bien organizado no
comidas sino 'armada' bien tu carpa no
podías dormir todo este proceso donde se
complicaba se conjugaban varias
inteligencias en lo que nosotros le
llamábamos la ciudad de lona y la ciudad
era una se cumplía la utopía de que
todos podemos ser iguales pero yo no
hablo de iguales si tiene más dinero o
menos dinero iguales en posibilidades de
ser felices porque lo primero que dije
nosotros les ponemos valor a las
palabras nosotros respondemos valor a
las acciones que tenemos y por eso por
dónde voy voy creando movimientos de
campamentos
el cfi y enfriar el día tenemos ya más
de 600 muchachos en campamento desde
hace 15 años dirigidos por ellos es una
ciudadela dirigida por ello está este
aprender en comunidad es lo que nos da
el punto yo soy porque los otros soy a
mí me importan que ustedes también sean
y aquí viene mi última palabra
última palabra que va a tener esta
trilogía de esta educación popular este
canto de educación popular es cuidado a
mí me habían enseñado desde la escuela
primeros no enseñan cuál es la
diferencia del hombre y los animales y
la naturaleza cuál es esa diferencia esa
es la razón la razón no nos ponían la
razón por el hombre lo único que piensa
razona son la escuela no si después no
llegas al colegio y llegas a veces a la
universidad pues tenía un profesor de
literatura que me decía no es el
lenguaje lenguaje el ser humano el
lenguaje hay que cuidar el lenguaje
porque estos pensamientos lo que sabemos
se vuelven palabras tus palabras tus
palabras se vuelven acciones sus
acciones se vuelven costumbres y forjar
la vida forja en tu carácter y de eso
depende la línea y la felicidad que tú
llevas por dentro es tu carácter cómo le
vas a poner lo que tú decía lo es esas
ideas profundas que marcan hacia donde
yo quiero ir
estas ideas
sólo hay una diferencia que no sean
individualistas en educación popular lo
que implica cómo llevamos la felicidad
como la podemos cantar todos no solo uno
no solo cuatro todos muchos es en la
educación popular y después leyendo
algunos libros mi tercera palabra
cuidado leyendo al teólogo leonardo boff
leyendo al propio heidegger habla en
ello de esta mitología griega de que el
dios cuidado es el que crea al hombre y
por eso en el adn nuestro en ladera
nuestro está una palabrita que se llama
cuidado
estamos condenados a cuidarnos
estamos condenados a cuidarnos y esto es
lo que yo quiero decirles a ustedes si
no nos cuidamos no va a perecer el mundo
el mundo va a seguir existiendo las
moléculas se van a reorganizar de nuevo
si no nos cuidamos los que parecemos
somos nosotros la raza humana ya estamos
hablando que otro ser humano es posible
pero solo es posible ser humano en
comunidad
y quisiera terminar así como comencé con
estas coplas de machado
que tenemos que cantar las nuestras
palabras tienen que cantar al pueblo
aunque pierdan el nombre de nosotros
porque solo así se hace realidad y se
hace eterna la testa y mucha gente no
está en uno
quisiera tener con una poesía de un
de un poeta nicaragüense julio sabala
conversando con un amigo cuando un amigo
le dice oiga
a quienes queremos que alfabetizar
dice bueno comienzan a contar aquí hay
que felicitar a los niños tales y al
pueblo no sé qué
y tú se puede salirse así pianos y piano
no no yo creo que tenemos que
alfabetizar a los que saben leer libros
a ellos tenemos que alfabetizar lo que
puede agregar tenemos que alfabetizar a
los que están demasiado preocupados por
lo que les pasa a los grandes edificios
de este mundo
tenemos que afrontarlo para que sepan
leer los gritos y el dolor de los
humanos muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]
e
[Aplausos]